remarquer messieurs pompidou premier
ministre chaban delmas président de
l'assemblée nationale béroud
vice-président du sénat andré malraux
ministre d'état chargé des affaires
culturelles
michel debré premier ministre du premier
septennat avant monsieur pompidou
monsieur foyer garde des sceaux ainsi
que les membres du conseil
constitutionnel et du cabinet du général
de gaulle après avoir proclamé à nouveau
les résultats officiels de l'élection
présidentielle monsieur gaston palewski
rendit à titre personnel un vibrant
hommage au général de gaulle puis le
président du conseil constitutionnel
après les remerciements du président de
la république devait lui remettre le
procès verbal de la proclamation de
l'élection document serré dans un
maroquin bleu